he's going for the beauty price in this  one uh if the black Rook takes this  white Rook then uh the White Queen takes  the bishop let's show this could cash  down to 10 seconds meanwhile uh so this  is really flashy Rook takes pawn bishop  takes Rook is simply met by Queen takes  and uh this piece is pretty much trapped  the black king  no Defenders and uh in the current  position okay he does go for this but if  Rook takes Rook this was the flashy one  Queen takes Bishop check due to this pin  uh the black king is doomed  so okay this is the current position on  the board now and how do you even defend  look at these they're cut off  wrong side of the board and it's over  there we go we have a result cash  resides oh no what a devastating result  for him he was winning this game against  Abdul sator of only a couple months  after losing a devastating game in the  Olympiad but it happens again abdisator  turns it around